[Music]
this podcast has bad words
hello everybody welcome to the
minimalist podcast where we discuss what
it means to live a meaningful life with
less my name's joshua fields milburn and
i'm ryan nicodemus and together we are
the minimalists what are you holding on
to
just
in
case
ryan aren't those the three most
dangerous words in the english language
yes now we touched upon this phenomenon
in our last film which is called less is
now which came out one year ago this
month on netflix oh wow but i want to
dive deeper today so on the public
podcast this week we're going to talk
about letting go of tens of thousands of
just in case items then this thursday on
the minimalist private podcast ryan and
i are going to talk about seven daily
habits to change your life forever well
i think we're actually gonna just
disagree about this a lot which will be
fun and we're gonna answer a bunch of
your surprise questions you can check
that out at patreon.com
the minimalists your support keeps our
podcast and youtube channel 100
advertisement free because
say it with me
advertisements
suck
yeah they do all right our first
question today is from
jessica on facebook
what are your thoughts on keeping
collectibles and valuable items just in
case they become more valuable one day
so you can pass them on to your kids
so the just in case rule was the very
first rule we came up with ryan
we also call it the 2020 rule yeah
yeah that was good that was uh
that's when i realized we were a couple
of hypocrites
because we went down to tampa or i guess
st petersburg florida which is in the in
the bay area and yeah we uh it was our
very first horse up we ever did
we opened up the trunk
and i'm like dude look at all this stuff
we brought with us it was like duffel
bags and garment bags and backpacks and
we got to talking about it we're like
why why do we have so we're only gone
for two weeks like why do you have so
much stuff with us
and uh what we realized is it was all
those just in case items um for me like
the most ridiculous one i could think of
was the
the the swimming trunks uh-huh or uh
like we're in florida i'm like we're
probably gonna go to the beach and go
swimming so wait you're not saying
swimming trunks are ridiculous but
something else was ridiculous yeah right
exactly yeah so i'm like we're probably
gonna go swimming uh so i'm gonna bring
a pair of swimming trunks and then i'm
like well those might get dirty uh-huh
so i'm gonna go ahead and bring two pair
well i've got three pair of them so i'll
just bring all three pairs of them but
like there's just so many items that um
that yeah we we both brought just in
case you know it's so funny ryan because
those three words they give us an excuse
to hold on to literally tens of
thousands
of items that we or might we might use
someday in some non-existent
hypothetical future yeah and we never
think about the cost of those things so
to address jessica's questions head on
she's talking about collectibles and
valuables holding on to them just in
case they might be more valuable one day
i was thinking about this question as we
were preparing for the podcast yesterday
i was walking around my neighborhood and
i saw this woman
and she was walking her dog and the dog
stopped a patch of grass and took a crap
on the grass
and of course like a wonderful dog owner
she got one of those little bags out and
picked up the dog poop
but she didn't hold on to the dog poop
just in case just in case it got
valuable right
now this one you're listening to this
you might say well this is absurd what
the heck is he talking about
but here's the truth
we hold on to a lot of crap
metaphorically in our lives now what did
she do with that as soon as she realized
it was crap she immediately threw it out
she got rid of it she disposed of it in
the most appropriate way for her right
yeah and i know that seems absurd but
then i started looking up what are the
what's the most expensive crap in the
world
we'll put a link to this in the show
notes oh wow here are the 10 most
expensive feces ever oh my god i'm not
going to read all of them one of them is
a pair of elvis's underwear that i think
they tried to sell for seven thousand
dollars we had poop stains on it oh my
god but this is an actual piece
of crap right i'll hold it up if you're
watching this on on youtube it's gross
right it's it's just
in fact to blur that out or something
danny
jordan's not here today we but we have
danny here just in case
um
[Laughter]
this is called lloyd's bank
first i thought it said lloyd banks like
the g-unit rapper i'm like man his crap
is worth this much money so this is the
most expensive poop in the world it's
from a viking
i guess like a couple thousand years ago
and it's 39 000
and so literally you could hold on to
crap because it might be worth tens of
thousands of dollars
someday wow just in case oh my goodness
dude that is um oh that is that's insane
well so really what i hear you saying
josh
is we have to be honest with ourselves
when we're holding on to something is it
just for when
you know does it fall in the seasonality
rule or are we holding on to a justin
case and if we are holding on to it just
in case is it crap
i mean
and no one not you nor i can look at
someone else and say well what you're
holding on to just in case it actually
is crap um only the person who owns that
piece of crap
can decide that i'll tell you though man
i
there's nothing wrong
with nothing wrong with you know holding
on to anything i mean that we're not
trying to make people feel guilty here
right um there's no shame yes but i'll
tell you man you
for i have brought this up a couple
times on the on the podcast you you got
me in the fifth grade for my birthday a
shaquille o'neal rookie card and you put
it in this really thick plastic case
and shaquille o'neal is a good player um
i have like this little
duffel bag full of like sentimental
stuff it's like one little you know i
got one little
one little thing it doesn't overflow
right i got a space for it yeah um and
the shaquille o'neal cards in there
uh-huh i looked it up the other day dude
it's worth like 500 bucks wow it's crazy
right yeah so like i have something that
i've been holding on to that is valuable
that really i kind of look at it at this
point as like a piece of art
um
maybe i should figure out how to display
that but you know long story short like
you know me ryan nicodemus one of the
minimalists like i have something that
yeah i'm holding on to
it has a bit of sentiment sentimental
sentimentality with it um it's worth
something it might be worth something in
the future i definitely have that in
mind but the problem is if we're not
honest with ourselves
then we hold on to everything we do hold
on to those tens of thousands of items
and man like let me tell you the worst
just in case item not the worst but like
the one of the funniest stories i
had this credit card this was back when
i was i don't know early 20s
that i it was just kind of an emergency
type credit card
so i had this credit card in my truck
uh just in case i forgot my wallet or it
was a just-in-case credit card yes
so
years go by at some point i like forgot
my wallet a couple times totally forgot
the credit card was in there and i
didn't find it until i sold that truck
and i was like pulling everything i'm
like oh my god i've i could use this a
couple times so all that to say is i was
holding on to so many just in case items
i didn't even know what i was holding on
to yeah you're talking about a few
things here one is you talked about the
duffel bag you have that is literally a
physical boundary for some of these
items now i would make an argument that
any of those things and there aren't
just in case items they are sentimental
items but
you you can make that distinction on
your own as you said ryan no one can
call your stuff crap i mean they can but
it's not it's not to decide in fact
there's someone who believes this piece
of crap that i just pointed out to you
is not crap it is worth tens of
thousands almost forty thousand dollars
for
this uh this poop it's the most
expensive crap in the world so you're
holding on to a lot of expensive crap
and if it's serving you in some way
then wonderful but the stories we often
tell ourselves or what
this might be worth something someday
but we don't think about the actual cost
of holding on to it right we only think
about the hypothetical worth of it in
some distant future oh it's gonna be
worth a thousand dollars five hundred
dollars a million dollars someday but
what is it costing you right now what is
it costing you emotionally what is it
costing you physically in terms of the
space that that item is taking up what
is it costing you mentally we're getting
ready to do next week an episode about
mental clutter the cluttered mind
how much mental clutter
is this physical clutter causing and
vice versa when you have a lot of mental
clutter what does that do quite often it
means we get more things around us to
try to organize or straighten the
clutter well that's another problem you
mentioned a few rules here ryan i'm sure
we'll touch on them in this episode the
justin case rule the just for win rule
the emergency items rule the seasonality
rule yeah there are 16 rules in total
that you and i have come up with they're
not really rules though these are
boundaries and you can download them for
free jessica theminimalists.com
rule book it's called the minimalist
rulebook you can download all 16 rules
for free and then we'll talk about the
difference here between just for win
just in case emergency items etc but
first let's move on to our callers if
you have a question or comment for our
podcast give us a call 406 219 7839 or
email a voice memo to podcast at
theminimalists.com looks like we have a
question here from stuart in georgia i'm
a full-time student in school right now
and trying to help make ends meet
financially i've been repairing
computers and
cell phones and doing tech repair
services for the past year and a half or
so
i have kind of a lot of necessary
clutter i feel like that comes with this
um there's a lot of times where
someone's hard drive may die
and instead of having to go to the store
to buy a new hard drive for you know 50
60 bucks
i have a stash of them um along with
cables you know a lot of odds and ends
that come in handy uh when doing jobs
but as i've kind of been getting rid of
junk it's kind of been weighing heavy on
me having all this extra clutter for
that
i just want your advice on you know how
i can maybe
alleviate some of the stress that comes
with having that clutter you know maybe
whether it's through organization
or just any kind of strategies that you
guys could
the still upon me i would appreciate
that um you know stopping fixing
computers isn't an option right now i
really need the money for it for school
um and having these things does
you know it saves a lot of money so
stuart first off i want you to know that
ryan and i aren't on this podcast nor
are we ever going around telling people
that they should get rid of something
that something is that is a just in case
item for one person might be a necessity
for someone else now you use these words
in a combination here that i want to
challenge you on a little bit ryan he
said he had some necessary clutter
that is an oxymoron in a way right
because clutter simply means something
that is getting in the way of what you
want to do but these things are actually
aiding what you want to do now is there
a better way to store it to organize it
to set up some boundaries with some
rules yeah in fact i would argue that
these aren't just in case items they
might be just for win items yeah well
you know this is what i love about the
the different rules that we've come up
with for ourselves is i think it's
pretty universal like take the
seasonality rule you know he could apply
this to his uh equipment
and say hey have i used this in the last
90 days am i going to use this in the
next 90 days and if not
he can give himself permission to let it
go now maybe it's 12 months for him 12
months have i used in the last 12 months
am i going to use it in the next 12
months but the key is setting up these
boundaries and here's what i love about
the 2020 rule
or the just in case rule is that
you know for 20
you're giving yourself permission to let
go of thousands of things so i'm willing
to bet not everything computers are
expensive but like the cables and the
cords and the little things you know if
he
if he's having trouble letting them go
after applying the seasonality rule
right this is where the 2020 rule comes
into place you could probably let go of
a lot of that stuff and replace it in
less than 20 minutes for less than 20
right which you know and i was talking
to mariah on the way here to the studio
and uh she was kind of talking about how
just in case items don't bother her as
much because of the waste like you know
she doesn't want to um put more things
in the landfill if it's not necessary
and we're having a conversation and i'm
like well you know
anytime you buy something off the shelf
you've already you've already done the
damage to the environment yes
there's batteries and certain things you
shouldn't bury any landfills but for all
intents and purposes you know when you
buy something off the shelf you've kind
of already done the damage to the
environment but that's not the first
place we tell people to go all these
cables and everything that he has he can
donate these he can find other people
who are going to use these put them on
craigslist i'm sure there's other
computer people out there who would
totally oh you got that cable i've been
looking for that and like now you can
maybe even make a little bit of money
off of these parts
um but but ideally you know if i was in
his position um i agree i would i would
probably reframe it not call it clutter
yeah it would be like neces
necessary
equipment that i needed
but i would have some very very um you
know
i want to say strict but that is kind of
a pejorative but i would just have some
very clear boundaries
on the things that i would keep how long
i'm going to keep them when am i going
to give myself permission to let them go
uh if i do need to bring something back
in my life like you know how am i going
to do that like this is what's going to
help him
um just go about this a little bit more
deliberately because there's obviously
some pain in his voice that's it i think
that's the problem and that's how we
know it's clutter to him right
because he's dealing with this but the
problem is you don't want to deal with
it you don't want to manage it right you
want to eradicate whatever the problem
is here and so how do we do that it's by
understanding that some of this might
actually be clutter and by applying some
of those boundaries you talked about
whether it's a seasonality rule or you
can extend it to a whole year because
some of these things he may want to get
rid of have i used this in the last year
if not that's probably a good indication
i'm not going to use it over the course
of the next year right or you can be
honest with yourself okay yeah but i do
plan on using it in march so having some
sort of deadline there and then as you
said
also setting up boundaries on the
letting go it's not simply throwing it
in a landfill it's trying to sell it
first you can sell it on ebay or
craigslist you can get a few bucks for a
ton of these things it adds up in fact
ryan you said if i was in your shoes
strangely we are in his shoes in in a
weird way right now in this studio
downstairs we have an annex which is a
storage space that we share with this
chef josh will be ruined
and and so when we moved in here like
this the studio that we're in doesn't
have a ton of extra space for equipment
that we have right no it has a closet
for a water cooler right that's about it
and and so we needed some extra space so
there's a chef that is in this building
we and he has this space we ask hey
you're using this for storage can we
share that with you and and pay you a
little bit of money each month but then
as we're storing things in there i've
been working with mallory because we got
to get rid of some of these things
because we're no longer using they
served a purpose for us and then we walk
through okay we can either sell it if it
doesn't sell in seven days we lower the
price if it doesn't sell in 30 days we
donate it
if you can't donate it recycle it and at
the absolute last resort you can trash
it but you go through that whole process
virtually everything we have down there
that we want to get rid of because it
doesn't fit within the 90 90 rule and
we're not going to hold on to anything
just in case yeah now there are a few
things we'll hold on to
just for
win
now there's another just in case item
that we hold on to as well they're
called emergency items so we had jumper
cables in the car for example a
emergency item is just a just in case
item you hope you'll never have to use
i'm not going to go into depth with that
because ryan and i did a whole podcast
episode episode 281 we'll put a link to
that in the show notes about emergency
items we also talked about our own
emergency preparations and we we talked
about our go bags that we have at home
and so we do have some emergency on so
you and i have a few just in case items
but only if they are emergency items
yeah now let's talk about just for win
items a just for win item is something
that may not fit within the seasonality
rule the 90 90 rule
but i know i'm going to need this at
some point
i'm certain i'm going to use it
consumables are a great example for this
because you're not going to buy your
lotion one squirt at a time you buy the
bottle of lotion right yeah
same with shampoo or toothpaste or
whatever it might be household cleaners
you buy enough
that you can store that it doesn't get
in the way so it's not necessary clutter
and if you have more storage space it
might make sense to even buy some things
in bulk if it saves you some money if
you happen to live in a home that has a
pantry and you want to get more canned
goods that fit in that space as long as
it doesn't weigh on you physically or
psychologically
then it's not clutter yeah i i think i
need to bring up too with the 2020 rule
because it does sound like uh almost
like a rule of privilege
like because he's like he's a college
you know he's a he's a college student
money's tight
you know i don't want him looking at
this and being like well i can't afford
to just go out and spend 20 every time i
need something which really none of us
can yeah i mean spending 20 every day or
twice a day that's that adds up to a lot
um
the beautiful thing about that 2020 rule
is that you know between you and i we've
had to use it what five or six times
over the last 11 years yeah and it was
never i never
re i might have had a twinge of like oh
i let that go about eight months ago now
i gotta go get another one right but
i never had like any deep regrets over
that
mainly because that 2020 rule has just
given me permission to let go of so much
clutter right so much crap yeah things
that are crap to you may not be crap to
someone else and so in a weird way by
letting go you're actually adding value
to other people's lives by selling
donating whatever it might be but if it
sits in our storage annex downstairs
beyond 90 days yeah then it's we know
we're not going to use it right so why
am i going to selfishly cling to that
thing and so there's probably stewart
there's probably a organization system
that works for you and the only way it's
going to work though the best way to
organize all those supplies and all that
stuff and the hard drives and the cables
is to get rid of anything you know that
is in the way
and then from there you'll be able to
put things in their place set up those
boundaries have a room or a space for
those things and not going beyond the
space that it fills being able to set up
that boundary with those rules is going
to bring you an incredible amount of
freedom
because otherwise you're just going to
keep accepting more and more and more
yeah and that becomes a kind of prison
this is one of those situations where
like organizing actually will help you
yes when you have so much stuff same
thing when it goes uh you know
just recently christmas time people got
christmas decorations they use them once
a year
it's a seasonality thing right um but
yeah it helps to like have those
organized so you can get to them easily
you know how to filter through them and
the same thing uh with with stuart here
yeah um organize organizing actually
will help you here and once you have
that system in place then you can start
putting these boundaries around yeah
you know i don't have any just in case
items in my home before we did this
episode i i went around and looked
throughout the home in fact i got rid of
a couple things we we had some christmas
cards from years past like you know with
me and ella and bex on them i'm like why
am i hold like i guess i was holding on
to them just in case i might need to use
them next year they're in a file cab and
i'm like i get rid of these
the only just in case items i have are
the emergency items that we we talk on
episode 281 about anyway stuart i want
to send you a copy of love people use
things it's our most recent book it came
out last year and in there we talk about
the 16 rules but also we talk about
there's a a chapter in there about our
relationship with our tools and our
distractions and our technology it's
called the relationship with creativity
chapter and so i think you'll find a lot
of value in that so podcast sean if you
could reach out to stuart send him a
copy of love people use things if you
want the book book we'll send that to
you or if you want the ebook or audio
book we're happy to send that to you as
well let's check in well we can't check
in with the patreon live stream right
now because our internet is out shout
out to our patreon supporters thank you
thank you thank you for keeping this
podcast advertisement free but we are
reaching out to facebook right now ryan
it looks like we have a few different
comments about just in case items
mallory
crystal has a comment for us i'm holding
on to so many pairs of blue jeans just
in case so many pairs taking up space
designer jeans that don't fit vintage
jeans that don't fit but they might one
day so i hold on to them just in case i
lose the weight oh this resonates with
me because i
i used to weigh a lot more than i weigh
now almost well i at one point i lost
100 pounds that was unhealthy but i um
i weighed about 80 pounds more than i
weigh now and so i had a lot of like
just in case items now a few problems
with that i'm going to hold on to this
just in case i gain the weight back
right
or i'm going to hold on to this just in
case it comes back into fashion one day
oh wow just in case it's trendy again
and so we start telling ourselves all of
these stories
but what if i let go of the things
because they're disempowering me
they're actually sort of weighing me
down keeping me in that past
and almost forbidding me from moving
forward in the direction that i want to
go yeah
man crystal i
if if i was in crystal's shoes i would
give myself a date an end date
like hey i'm gonna if i don't if i can't
fit into these clothes by you know the
end of the year
then i'm gonna get rid of them right um
but
this is
all i really wanna tell crystal is you
gotta be honest with yourself
are you really gonna put the effort into
losing the weight i hope you do yeah i i
hope that you come up with a plan and
you stick to it and you get to fit in
those size three jeans again yes i would
love to fit in some size three jeans
josh
[Laughter]
like a scarf right yeah right but you
know what i'll never fit into a pair of
size three jeans yeah right and and so i
think with with anything like this by
the way you can always buy a new pair of
size three jeans as a reward for getting
down to where you wanted to be
anyway you don't have to cling to those
things in fact by letting go and saying
hey i'm going to move forward and
wherever i end up wherever my arrival
point is and all the points along the
way i can adjust accordingly you don't
need the things from the past to make
the future version of you you could
tweet that podcast sean yeah
no man i have uh i've gotten rid of a
couple things that
i've just outgrown and
[Music]
uh way i look at it when i let go of a
couple things because like when i was
in high school i think i was a size like
32 waist
you know i don't think i'll ever get
back to a size 32 waist what are you
like a 28 i mean 29. oh my god
i'm so jealous you could fit into those
size three jeans 29 34. you're right
so um i remember
when i was letting go of a lot of those
clothes and i was going through this
this same thing
um and this was like you know my early
20s i gained weight couldn't fit into
stuff and i was like well
probably not going to like lose the
weight anytime soon right if i do end up
losing the weight
and i need to buy smaller jeans
what a good problem to have ah so like i
kind of just thought to myself like i
hope i have to buy new jeans after
letting these go
yeah yeah because what you're saying is
i hope that i get to move forward and be
the version of myself that i want to
become yeah alabama we got one more
question here one more comment rather
from lisa on facebook one of my favorite
just in case items is a three by five
inch notebook that holds the list of
books and music that left my home if i'm
ever in need of literature or stumped
for music to listen to i'll refer to the
list and see if i'm actually even
interested in buying or borrowing the
book or downloading the music or buying
the cd you know this isn't a just in
case i don't and so give yourself
permission to keep this this is
something you're getting value from
regularly yeah anything that you're
currently getting value from regularly
is by definition by its very essence not
a just in case item the just in case
items are things we hold on to that
we're not using they're not serving us
they're not adding value to our lives
and because they're not adding value to
our lives they're clutter they're
getting in the way anything that's
serving you though
how wonderful is that ryan and i are not
against things we're not against
material possessions what we're against
is the burden of thinking we're supposed
to have certain things just in case we
might need them someday in some
non-existent future ryan what time is it
you know what time it is it's time for
the lightning round where we answer your
text messages you can text your comments
and questions to
937-202-4654 yes indeed now during the
lightning round that's where ryan and i
do our best to answer questions with a
short shareable less than 140 character
response we put the text to these
minimal maxims in the show notes so you
can copy and share our pithy answers on
social media if you'd like and now you
can find all of our minimal maxims in
one place minimal
maxims.com thanks to our good friend
jessica lynn williams sue has a question
for us alabama
how do you deal with the i told you so
when you got rid of a just-in-case item
and later needed it it's like being
taunted that you got rid of it
but first off i guess my first question
would be who is who are you hanging out
with this is saying i told you so why
are you hanging out with jerks sue
right now here's the other problem
sometimes
we beat ourselves up yeah so if sue was
doing the
i told you so to herself um
then simply stop the i told you so with
yourself yeah here's the thing ryan
talked about this earlier
getting rid of the just in case items
is
you're essentially paying a little bit
of money let's call it 20 bucks a year
to give yourself permission to let go
yeah of tens of thousands of just in
case items and so guess what you could
also go around telling yourself i told
you so you'd never need that waffle iron
again yeah i told you you would never
need those excess towels that are in the
closet in the basement i told you you
wouldn't need all those random hardware
parts that are up in the attic i told
you so that you won't need all of that
junk the dvds the cds the walkman the
discman all of the exercise equipment
and camping equipment you never use i
told you so i told you you would never
need that well you could tick-tock that
danny
so sue here's something pithy for you
if you ever regret letting go
you can simply let go
of the regret boom here's the thing
about regret
we often regret something because we
tell ourselves a story
i did one thing but i should have done
some other thing
there is no should there only could so
yes could you have done something
different well yeah of course in
hindsight
there's a part in and love people use
things
hindsight is 50 50.
it's my favorite gym horrorism a boss of
mine a mentor of mine back in my early
20s he
i screwed up i really
messed up with this customer
and he meant to say hindsight is 2020
the regular colloquialism
but on the phone he just slipped he said
hindsight is 50 50.
and i remember it being so profound
because really what he was saying is
look
it's going to go either way right so you
might as well do the thing that makes
you feel
well
the thing that feels the most
appropriate to you the thing that feels
true to you because holding on to the
excess stuff certainly doesn't feel true
it feels like a burden
and anything that feels like a burden
over a long enough timeline actually
robs you of your freedom and so do you
want to give up that freedom just
because uh someone might say i told you
so yeah
man
i mean
i think
i i try not to tell people i told you so
but i'm sure i've said that before in
the past right um same but yeah i
absolutely
would
have a
much different conversation
with someone who kept telling me i told
you so about some trying to make me feel
guilty
about a decision i made like first off i
have my own guilt i don't need anyone
else to make me feel more guilty about
anything
so um so yeah sue but you know here's
the thing about regrets regrets are a
symptom
of something that could have gone a
different way
and that's okay we life is filled with
regrets
and uh well my fifth answer is this
i deeply regret if i died
without any regrets
[Music]
[Laughter]
because if you if you're not having any
regrets and that means you're not really
getting outside your comfort zone you're
not trying anything new you're not
you're not uh putting yourself out there
yeah and it's it's okay to live a very
safe life and cushy life and you know go
with uh
go with what you know is going to happen
to have as much certainty as possible
like that's i'm not saying that it's not
okay to do that but if you step outside
your comfort zone you're probably gonna
live a much more meaningful life and
yeah you're probably gonna have a couple
regrets along the way amen
and
the studies actually show that the safer
we make our world the more we sort of
put ourselves in danger
because everything becomes dangerous to
us because we're not prepared right
we if we've nerfed everything that we're
not actually prepared for the
difficulties of everyday
life of everyday living now we've seen
some of this over the last few years
where
with especially with lockdowns and stuff
maybe we became a little overly cautious
in certain circumstances
and we had to adjust accordingly
realizing like oh yeah this
level of caution makes sense for a
period of time
but if we live in a state of perpetua
perpetual caution
it's not the place from which we grow
it's not the place place from which we
thrive
amen we got so much more to talk about
but first real quick for right here
right now here's one thing that's going
on in the life of the minimalists ryan
next week we're finishing the love
people use things for
man 20 cities in total we have uh three
left we have chicago and columbus and
minneapolis and you can join us at any
of those events
themminimalists.com by the way we're
postponing our two canadian dates
because of well certain restrictions and
local restrictions venue restrictions
right now they've limited the number of
people in canada who can show up at
events no christopher walken look-alikes
aloud
[Music]
my hair terrified them thanks canada but
we'll uh we'll get up there soon find
all the details
theminimalists.com tour or you can find
all 20 of our events the love people use
thing tore events over at patreon.com
the minimalists
alabama you got something for us here
are some voicemail comments and insights
from our listeners
hi josh and ryan my name is zeal from
jersey city new jersey in regards to
episode 204 as an artist i find it
helpful to add my own expiration dates
on my supplies so i can use them within
a month or a year this helps me set a
date usually with a permanent marker on
the packaging or on a post-it note
hey guys this is jessica calling from
boston about episode 190 on positive
thinking you guys were discussing
whether or not it's a good idea to try
and be positive all the time even on
your bad days faking it till you make it
etc
and i definitely think it's a strength
and a skill to be able to look on the
positive side of things but at the same
time i think it's really important to
dig deep and figure out the why and
everything that comes up in our lives
whether it's good or bad
after discovering that we have like 60
000 thoughts a day and about how 80 of
them can be negative and self-critical i
thought that especially on the really
bad days where that percentage might be
a little bit higher it might be
beneficial to actually just minimize the
total amount of thoughts that you have
instead of using your energy to try to
be positive all day which can get quite
draining actually
so i started to implement this really
cool two-step process on the days where
i just can't seem to be positive at all
and it's really been helping me out a
lot so step one is i try to just spend
my entire day being in a constant state
of awareness and meditation
so i'm just absorbing paying attention i
don't give any prolonged thought to
anything at all i'm not judging
and i do this whether i'm at home all
day i'm going to work or hanging out
with friends whatever it is
i just try to stay in the moment and
then whenever
any negative thoughts try to creep back
up um i remind myself to get back to
that state so overall this limits the
amount of total thoughts i have
throughout the day which then
limits the amount of negativity i end up
spending my um focus on right and it
gives me kind of like a mental break
and then step two is that um hopefully
the next day when i wake up i'm feeling
better i take some time to reflect and
journal so the idea is not to
ignore your bad feelings which can get
quite dangerous and destructive over
time but you wait for a better day when
they feel less overwhelming and
crippling so that you can process them
this just seems like a really healthy
way to love and be genuine to myself and
i hope that this helps some of the
listeners who maybe don't do well when
it comes to putting that smile on on
those tough days
all right y'all before we get to our
added value segment this week it looks
like kathy one of our lovely patreon
supporters has a testimonial for us the
minimalist private podcast kind of snuck
up on me when i was listening to someone
else's decluttering workshop i was
failing miserably but you two were
different you helped me understand the
why of my addiction to stuff i am now in
the process of letting go and not
beating myself up for the past five
years love people use things is a much
happier way to live thank you both for
the gentle nudges on your private
podcast the gentle nudges ryan yes i
mean sometimes they're a little bit more
blunt than gentle especially on the
private podcast yeah we roll up our
sleeves and let our hair down and other
mixed metaphors yes
i love that book
that sounds like a great like grammar or
writing book doesn't it yeah it really
does speaking of great books uh our
added value segment this week our friend
dave dave ramsey has a new book out now
here's why i wanted to talk about this
because well
we've been on his show a bunch of times
he was in our netflix documentary the
second one les is now
and one of the things that he does so
well is he helps people understand
why it is not necessary to demonize
wealth
so his new book is called baby steps
millionaires the subtitle is how
ordinary people build extraordinary
wealth and how you can too and what i
like about this and there are a few
chapters in here i'll hold it up for
youtube if you're watching the show on
youtube here
but
what i like about the book here is he
not only did he talk about that large
study of millionaires you remember we
had chris hogan on the podcast to talk
about millionaires they did the largest
ever study of millionaires and you
figure out that oh
most millionaires are just average
people like teachers and accountants and
and people who over a long period of
time invest their money in a responsible
way such evil
[Laughter]
all those evil teachers
oh no i no i love how uh yeah he just
kind of dispels it and there's a few
other things here in in the book so
there's a a chapter in here about how
wealth is not evil
how equal is not always fair
which
man that might piss some people off but
he goes into depth and explains that um
the wealthy are not evil the toxic views
of wealth in our culture also will
wealth
ruin my kids i know that's one thing
that it's
it makes sense to worry about right
because quite often adverse adversity in
our lives is what shapes us
into being
stronger better more resilient human
beings yeah right and so i think that is
a concern and of course he addresses
that as well uh on his website right now
if you go to actually we'll just put a
link to it in the show notes i don't get
anything for telling you this ryan
doesn't get anything we don't do any
sponsorships but we like dave he has a
bundle for the new book baby steps
millionaires you'll get the audiobook
the e-book the book book and i think he
even includes an app and a course and
and uh his first book the the big one
the total money makeover and so the
total money makeover has the seven baby
steps in it uh to get out of debt you
and i have bought this book by the case
we would hand it out to people yeah in
fact i still buy that book by the case
and we'll hand it out to folks quite
frequently when they're trying to get
out of debt well the fourth baby step in
in that book is about investing you know
taking 15 of your income and finding
ways to grow that money over a
protracted period of time and this book
really just dives deep into that fourth
baby step
and takes you deep it's called baby
steps millionaires i'll put a link to it
in the show notes by the way ryan we
have a bunch more surprise questions
this week like
many people don't even have 400 for an
emergency so how do cash savings and
lines of credit figure into just in
case
also help
i hang on the gifts from others that i
don't use just in case they might visit
me
what should i say
if they ask about a gif that i ended up
getting rid of plus a question about
what about very expensive just-in-case
items
eggs
for 39 000 pieces of poop oh my god
what about those expensive just the case
items that can be replaced plus a
million more questions about letting go
for the minimalists if you want to hear
all that check out the minimalist
private podcast this week visit
patreon.com
the minimalist to subscribe and get your
personal link so that our weekly private
podcast plays in your favorite podcast
app you'll also gain immediate access to
hundreds of hours of private archives
recordings of live events exclusive home
tours and our private community of
thousands of open-minded minimizers like
you you can follow the minimalists on
tik-tok instagram facebook and twitter
at the minimalists if you want our
podcast show notes in your inbox sign up
for our email list at the
minimalists.com on behalf of ryan
nicodemus podcast shawn alabama jordan
no more social jess danny unknown emma
the immigrant and the rest of our team
i'm joshua fields milburn reminding you
to love people and use things
because the opposite never works thanks
for listening y'all we'll see you next
time
[Music]
every little thing
you think that you need
every little thing you think that you
need
every little thing
that's just feeding your greed oh i bet
that you'll be fine
without it